dr jello knows
the risk he's facing ebola almost killed
him in 2014
with the resurgence of the deadly virus
he fears his own patients may
unknowingly carry it
putting him and others in danger
i had aches diarrhea a fever and i
vomited
i self-isolated sleeping in my car to
protect my wife and children
eventually i sought treatment and
in a survived address the government
announces the closing of markets a ban
in public gatherings including weddings
and funerals
events health officials describe as
super spreaders
with checkpoints throughout the country
guinea is now on high alert so are
neighboring countries
multiple people in contact with the
nurse that died from the virus two weeks
ago
are now in hospital in the capital
konacri and
in nzerikore where authorities are still
trying to trace close contacts
ebola is available contagious than kovid
but has
a higher mortality rate his team is
sequencing
blood samples in order to understand how
the virus that had disappeared in 2015
after killing over 11 thousand people in
west africa
resurfaced six years later again
in guinea's forest region
sequencing allow us to understand where
the virus is coming from
this helps the epidemiological
investigation maybe the virus came from
human contact or from an animal carrying
the virus that was eaten by someone
sequencing will allow to retrace and
understand what we are dealing with
chimpanzees and bats are natural
reservoirs for the virus their meat
is consumed by people in the guinea
forest region where the outbreak started
and while the country's health minister
says it has ebola vaccines
the doses expired last december
meanwhile in the democratic republic of
congo
health workers are vaccinating patients
after the virus resurfaced last week
a woman contracted the virus from her
husband who had earlier
recovered from ebola researchers
are still trying to understand the virus
back in guinea the who is dispatching
vaccines as quickly as possible to
protect
frontline health workers who are already
overstretched and overwhelmed fearing
what is to come
nicholas hawk al jazeera dakar